[Music]
start doing those chores around the
house for extra cash tell your
girlfriend or boyfriend
you need a break for a few weeks or in
my case ask your wife for access to the
bank account a new month means new games
to buy and April 2019 is an absolute
beast
here's eight games worth your pennies
this month I'm starting with the
PlayStation 4 exclusive days gone how
can I sum this up in a single sentence
how about an action-adventure
post-apocalyptic Survival title we play
as deacon sent John taking on the zombie
horde sorry we can't call them zombies
these are free cos the main difference
is that they sleep they drink they eat
they even migrate when the weather
changes these are zombies 2.0 the newts
are child freaker's who won't attack
unless you're weakened swarmers hang
around in groups and attack in a swarm
there are even infected animals to
battle such as wolves and bears the main
takeaway which sets days gone apart from
other zombie titles is the amount of
freaker's hunting you down
simultaneously it's mind-blowing
days gone has around 30 hours of play
time and six hours of cutscenes those
that have played the demos and early
access have stated how well their
narrative forms and the bond we have
with deacon some go as far as to compare
the quality of the story of days gone to
horizon zero dawn and the last of us
high praise indeed
days gone releases on April 26th only on
PlayStation 4 another epic game releases
in April Mortal Kombat 11 it's been four
years since the last MK game and people
are ready to rip body parts off and
impale heads once again the fatalities
return as do customization as seen in
the injustice series allowing us to
fine-tune the look and feel of our
favorite one-on-one murderous new
features include the fatal and crushing
blows fatal blows are only available
once your foe is down under 30% health
and that can be wiped out almost
instantaneously fatal blows essentially
replace the x-ray super moves from MK X
and can only be used once per fight
crushing blows on the other hand our
cinematic attacks designed to look
disgusting and awesome at the same time
a signature move passe a new flawless
block mechanic has been added for pro
players to utilize which when timed
absolutely perfectly will allow for a
monumental comeback even with a morsel
of life it's possible to come back in
Mortal Kombat 11 so it's not over until
you're in multiple pieces on the ground
you grabbing it I'd love to know your
thoughts I'm looking forward to watching
all the fatalities with my four-year-old
son what do you mean you're scouring for
life Mortal Kombat 11 releases on ps4 PC
and Xbox one on April 23rd with a switch
version coming in May how about a free
game that wants your time rather than
your money
this is dauntless dauntless is an
online-only role-playing game in which
you play as a Slayer choose a weapon
which takes your fancy and travel to
nearby islands to take down behemoths
each of these massive beasts fights
differently meaning tactics are
important luckily we are able to team up
with friends to challenge those tougher
beasts which improves dauntless tenfold
we already know it but gaming with
friends makes everything better at
present were unsure on team size on
console but I'm expecting it to be four
but we'll have to wait for a few final
details to come out when the game
releases sometime in April yeah no
specific date just yet but it's
confirmed for the month of April each
behemoth can award items from their
chopped up tales for example which are
then used to improve weapons and items
to make up the core gameplay loop of
dauntless hunt killed up great here's
something cool if we kill a snow powered
beast we can utilize ice in our weapons
allowing us to harness that power I
don't know about you but I am very
interested in dauntless it's already out
on the PC and ps4 Xbox and switch will
be getting dauntless in the month of
April yet another zombie game hits
console and PC this month World War Z
world was dead I'm gonna go with Z
please don't judge me World War Z is
based on the movie of the same name
which is based on the book playing in
third person in groups of up to four we
take on large numbers of zombies using
traps to slow them down and other
emplacements to maim and restrain the
undead buggers if you played left 4 dead
and the division you already have a good
understanding of how it feels but World
War Z goes deeper than that we have 6
classes to choose from gunslinger
Hellraiser slasher medic fixer and the
exterminator
each of which have their own
unique perks and play styles but the
entire game is based on survival but
it's not just that it's surviving with
limited resources the game goes as far
as to give you worse items bonds if
you're doing well ouch but if you're
playing terribly like me it could give
you a helping hand to World War Z
released on April 16th on ps4 Xbox one
and PC let's quickly look through a few
titles which may go under the radar
Earth Defense boss iron rain is out on
ps4 on April 11th it has a small but
dedicated audience in the West iron rain
attempt to make the game more serious
than the other seven titles in the
series anyone play these can you let us
know what we're missing what's the
appeal of this game series another
fighting game releases in the same month
as Mortal Kombat Power Rangers battle
for the grid this fighter is much more
child-friendly and retails at $20 u.s.
for the standard edition we have
conflicting release dates on this one it
looks like April the 2nd worldwide and
an early EU release of March 28 fade to
silence releases on April 30th a
survival RPG set in the snowy cold of
post-apocalyptic winter there are
freakish looking zombified things to
battle and run from but it's the RPG
elements which makes this game worthy of
pointing out April 30th if you're
interested and finally an indie classic
Super Meat Boy returns in Super Meat Boy
forever
on PC ps4 Xbox one iOS Android basically
every device known to man 7000
side-scrolling levels playing as a lump
of meat or a girl made of bandages
trying to find their little baby nugget
indie games are great Super Meat Boy is
extremely hard challenging frustrating
but above all rewarding when you finally
pass the stage you've been stuck on for
three hours April 26 look out for it so
there we have it eight new games for the
month of April 2019 I can't wait to
decapitate people in Mortal Kombat 11
and 2 outlived a zombie apocalypse in
days gone sorry not zombies free cos
I'll get you sweet one day I'm Madden
from PlayStation grenades you can find
me on twitter i'm adam grenade it's been
a pleasure
i'll see you next time
[Music]